[Music]
[Applause]
play of the day coming up we've got bowl
games coming up starting at noon today
it's of course the relia quest Bowl
Mississippi State and Illinois
Citrus Bowl LSU and Purdue the Cotton
Bowl USC Tulane oh Saucy also the Rose
Bowl it's the granddaddy of them all
it'll be Utah versus Penn State Andy
Staples covers college football for the
athletic host of The Andy Staples Show
podcast he was on site at the Peach Bowl
between Georgia and Ohio State on
Saturday night and he joins us now
what was your expectation over the
weekend with these two games
I expected Georgia and Michigan to cover
comfortably and uh was wrong on both
counts
biggest surprise was it what Ohio state
did to George's defense or what TCU did
to Michigan
I think it's what TCU did to Michigan
because Ohio State and Georgia
athletically are fairly evenly matched
so we'd seen Georgia had the potential
to get beat deep a few times and we knew
Ohio state had some of the best
receivers in the country and probably
the best receiver in the country in
Marvin Harrison Jr so that wasn't as
shocking but TCU just physically
completely toe-to-toe with Michigan
didn't look like there was any issue at
all and it
shows us we got to kind of reevaluate
how we look at talent and and all that
they do play the games for a reason and
you've got kind of a new Dynamic with
the transfer portal TCU had I believe 13
transfers who played this year so the
their talent Dynamic changed
considerably over the year and Sunny
Dykes just did an incredible job taking
over a roster that that Gary Patterson
did a good job stocking in the first
place but then taking it to another
level how surprised are you that George
is favored by 13 and a half I'm not
surprised at all that's what I would
expect but I would say
maybe knock that down a few points based
on what we saw this weekend I think you
know the Vegas Power Rankings don't
change as as quickly as our minds might
in this situation but but I'd say maybe
knock that down because I think you
looked at the the speed that TCU had you
look at the explosiveness that TCU had
offensively and you say okay they can
probably hit some place on Georgia too
who had a worse coaching night of the
Big Ten coaches Harbaugh or Ryan Day
I I think Harbaugh because it you're
getting cute with the Philly special
early on when you should just be handing
off course they try to just hand it off
and fumble although I do think I thought
they got screwed on the the taking the
touchdown off the board but
for me the hardball thing that that just
made me kind of yell at the screen was
what when you were trying to come back
why are you bleeding that play clock so
much I mean no sense of urgency
whatsoever and
you can you can use Tempo like it's okay
to use Tempo in the midst of a game when
you're not necessarily in your
two-minute offense and I I just didn't
understand that because they were doing
so well they were gassing tcu's defense
because they were making explosive plays
just go score and and then try to get a
stop
do you think Ohio State fans were
rooting for Michigan to win
no
no because I think Ohio State fans
before that Georgia game started were
very pessimistic about their team's
chances against Georgia so they didn't
want to see Michigan win because if
Michigan won then there's a chance
Michigan wins the national title now I I
was feeling very bad for Michigan fans
when it looked like Ohio state was going
to beat Georgia because if you beat Ohio
State on the field and then Ohio State
goes on to win the national title that's
just a crushing moment we've seen it
before I mean Auburn beat Alabama in
2017 and then Alabama went on to win the
national title but in that particular
rivalry in the Ohio State Michigan
rivalry especially given the Dynamics of
it the past 20 years that would have
been just brutal
I thought Kirby Smart had some really
interesting observations after the game
where he was talking about Stetson
Bennett basically saying you better play
better against TCU
yeah I mean he threw for 400 yards and
three touchdowns against against Ohio
State he played okay now there were some
throws that he definitely liked back uh
there was a there was a pull on a read
option that if he'd hand it off it's
probably a touchdown so yeah he made
some but it's funny because that's just
how the dynamic between those two guys
works and I I don't think you're going
to have to to convince Stetson Bennett
to lock in on this game but that's just
that's just how they go and I what a
story this would be to go from from
walk-on quarterback to potentially
two-time National Champion quarterback
and I I think this what this has shown
this entire season has shown you Stetson
Bennett is not just a great story though
he is a great college quarterback and I
do think he has a pro future now do I
think he's going to be a a 10-year
starter in the NFL no but could he be on
that chase Daniel Plan abso freaking
lutely he belongs in that league but I
wonder how history is going to treat
Stetson Bennett
let's say he wins back-to-back national
championships
what do you think
I think he's going to be viewed as one
of the great all-time college
quarterbacks I mean there have been
plenty of guys who were incredible
college quarterbacks who didn't
necessarily pan out in the NFL that
there's a hat behind me on my screen
that's that's the 1996 Heisman Team hat
that went to everybody who was a
teammate of Danny werfel Danny werfel is
one of the greatest college quarterbacks
who ever played every the only thing we
remember of him in the NFL is he's
playing for the Saints and he gets hit
so hard that his helmet spins around on
him but that doesn't take away the fact
that he was an all-time great college
quarterback and that is what Stetson
Bennett will be forever but I will say
I think prior to
this season for like the hardcore
college football fans and then prior to
Saturday for the Casual college football
fan people were like oh he's he's fine
but they just need a replacement level
quarterback because they have all that
Talent around him I think you saw he
made a lot of plays in that game and I'm
not sure a lot of other quarterbacks
make and I think you realize now he's
pretty special he's Andy Staples he
covers college football for the athletic
what are you hearing with the transfer
portal
uh it's it slowed down a little bit now
because you had the the open window in
December and everybody started moving
the the most recent news is that Grayson
McCall the the Coastal Carolina
quarterback is headed back to Coastal
Carolina he had looked around at some
schools and and he's going to wind up
staying for that final year at coast of
Carolina which we've now seen three
group of five quarterbacks do that where
they've they've looked around and then
wound up staying at the at the group of
five school out you're gonna see one
today in the in the Cotton Bowl Michael
praditt at Tulane and then Austin Reed
at Western Kentucky was the second
leading Pastor in the country this year
he looked around I think Louisville was
really really in it when Jeff Brahm got
the job but he ended up deciding to stay
at Western Kentucky so you know for
everybody who said it's just going to
make these teams a farm system
that's not necessarily the case you're
seeing some guys make choices for
different reasons I wonder about Ohio
State's quarterbacking situation losing
CJ Stroud
and you have you have a wide receiver
who's probably a top five pick in the
NFL in Marvin Harrison yep okay
could you see Marvin Harrison
looking at the transfer portal
I could you mean if you wanted to play
with say USC Caleb Williams yes
I could see that I could see you get the
same text from the same people I do but
I don't know if that's the case I mean
here's the thing Ohio state is still
stacking five-star quarterbacks on their
roster you know they've got Devin Brown
from Utah they've got we'll see who
winds up winning that job but remember
Marvin Harrison's been watching these
guys play so
he knows that they can play or not
already so I'll be curious to see what
he does but he really knows that Caleb
Williams can play oh absolutely but it's
it it's hard to imagine somebody leaving
Ohio State for USC but that would be
interesting if it happened and I'll tell
you why because the assumption is that
the rich just get richer in this in this
situation
that would kind of be a little Robin
Hood action I mean USC's not poor by any
stretch but they are poorer than Ohio
State in this scenario and wait a minute
they just took the coach and the
quarterback from Oklahoma
uh-huh this isn't Little Red Riding Hood
here did they take an elite defense uh
no they sure didn't seem like they did
they did forget about that they they so
Ohio Lincoln Riley is not known for
being a defensive genius I I have
ordered that but if if you're if you're
deciding who to play for next year
well I I would think about the fact that
you need some first rounders on the
other side of the ball too Ohio State
still has those USC we don't know if
they're going to have those yeah but
you're always throwing the football
because you got to throw the football
because your defense isn't very good
that's exactly right well and that's
that's probably what Jordan Addison was
saying you know Jordan Addison is at
Pitt last year he wins the balitnikov
his offensive coordinator leaves his
receivers coach leaves in his first
round quarterback's gone he goes through
spring practice he's like well this is
going to be the same thing
catch passes from Kayla Williams yeah uh
I'll leave you with this if you had to
bet on Harbaugh his future
I know that you're already hearing
Broncos interested in Harbaugh Harbaugh
has flirted with this the Vikings last
year Jim Harbaugh you know you get back
to the Final Four
what do you think he is uh what his
future is it's it's interesting because
I was on my podcast last week and I said
you know could it be could it have been
that he was flirting with the Vikings
just because the Vikings were a great
situation you know you have Kirk Cousins
you have Justin Jefferson and and as
you've seen now yesterday
notwithstanding they've had a very good
season and so maybe he was looking at
and saying if I'm going to go back to
the NFL I want it to be in a good
situation and then I I get texts from
people who who know things the following
me going oh no no he would he would take
one of the jobs available now and I'm
like are you really sure because like
the Colts job the Broncos job those jobs
are pretty bad right now those don't
look like they're they're a whole lot of
fun so if he really wants to go to the
NFL and he take one of those jobs I
think you're better off staying at
Michigan because what he's built at
Michigan being able to beat Ohio state
two years in a row go to the playoff two
years in a row the fact that they really
seem to have solved how the transfer
portal works that that they may they've
made the transfer portal and net
positive every year for them
I think he's got something special going
there I think it'd be crazy to take a
bad NFL job but if he really wants to be
back in the NFL and they're offering I I
would get it but I don't think he should
leave I think he's got potentially a
national title season brewing in there
somewhere in Michigan you know the thing
I wondered about when I'm watching them
is they do run the football they didn't
run the football very well against TCU
they lacked explosive players
explosive guys on the outside but yeah
you know get a get a great tight end or
get a great wide receiver that's what
has always surprised me with with
Harbaugh that being a former quarterback
you know not having those Dynamic
players well I think you saw with
Alabama this year
those players are hard to find they
don't grow on trees and like Alabama had
had one or two or in one case one year
they had four of them incredible
receivers every year and you saw what
happened when they had just above
average receivers this year was a very
different season for them so those
special guys are hard to find Ohio state
has Brian Hartline who's maybe the best
receivers coach in the country one of
the best receiver you know recruiters of
receivers in the country and that's why
they've always got you know whether it's
Jackson Smith and jig but Garrett Wilson
they had Jameson Williams before Alabama
did you know the they have the mecca
Buca they have Marvin Harrison Jr
there's there's stockpiling them so it's
it's it's hard to crack into that when
there are only so many of those humans
walking around
great stuff as always Andy thank you
Happy New Year we appreciate you joining
us thanks Dan that's Andy Staples covers
college football for the athletic